recently i was watching an episode of
millennial money when i heard this
they announced the tesla cyber truck
will be uh i believe discontinued and
they're refunding the development april
fools
while the article was an april fool's
joke it did get me wondering what
happened to this cyber truck when elon
musk announced the vehicle at the end of
2019 we saw some of the most polarizing
reactions
many were quick to laugh at it calling
it a polygon on wheels while others felt
that this is exactly what tesla needed
in order to stick out inside of the
saturated pickup truck market following
the announcement hundreds of thousands
of people put in pre-orders which
eventually turned into millions while
this level of interest is great it
doesn't exactly mean much given that the
deposit amount is only 100
and the lowest and cyber truck starts at
just under 40 000. with all of that
being said though the cyber truck was
supposed to hit the roads months ago at
the end of 2021
this was originally postponed to 2022
but at the beginning of the year this
was postponed indefinitely
tesla has gone ahead and removed all
delivery estimates from their website
and you can't even configure a cyber
truck anymore
you now have to wait until production
years to do that on top of this in the
latest quarterly earnings call when elon
was questioned about whether tesla would
start roadster or cybertron production
this year he responded with a quote that
wouldn't make any sense clearly it
doesn't look like the cyber truck will
be coming out anytime soon so here's
when the cyber truck may actually hit
the roads and the main factors that are
holding back cyber truck production
one of the biggest factors holding back
cyber truck production is rampant
inflation
i'm sure you guys have seen the numbers
month after month we're seeing cpi
readings coming in at five six seven
percent and one of the biggest culprits
boosting these readings is car prices
originally this price hike was mainly
manifesting within the used car market
and supply was extremely low but this
has slowly carried over onto the new
market as well after all basically every
raw material you can think of
semiconductors and manual labor have all
risen substantially so it's not
surprising that it costs a lot more to
produce the same vehicle today than it
did a few years ago and tesla is just as
susceptible to these price hikes as any
other automotive company the model 3 for
example reached a price of 35 000 at the
start of 2019
now it should be noted that you had to
jump through a lot of hoops and give up
a lot of features to get a model 3 for
this price but it was possible today
however the lowest in the model 3 cost
47 000 or twelve thousand dollars more
not to mention the self-driving package
price has increased to twelve thousand
dollars itself meanwhile hundreds of
thousands of people have locked in a
cyber truck for forty thousand dollars
and self-driving for eight thousand
dollars this means that these guys that
literally got a cyber truck with
self-driving for the same price as a
base level model 3. realistically tesla
would charge a minimum of 70 000 for
such a vehicle today meaning that
they're in the hole by 22 000 on each
base model cyber truck now while elon
promised that fsd prices would be
honored if locked in tesla doesn't have
to honor the purchase price of the cyber
truck itself but at the same time they
kind of do while tesla won't face any
hurdles legally when it comes to
increasing the price of cyber trucks
they would likely face a pr nightmare if
they increased prices just take a look
at what happened to rivien
similar to the cyber truck rivian
revealed their r1t pickup truck well
before the pandemic and they price these
models accordingly but with rampant
inflation rivian decided to increase
prices by as much as twenty thousand
dollars even for pre-order customers
over the next few days rivien received
so much backlash and so many people
canceled that rivienne reversed this
decision and announced that they would
honor pre-order prices considering this
it would be extremely difficult for
tesla to get away with raising pre-order
prices and the longer they wait to start
production the worse
the last thing you want to do is tell
someone who's been waiting six years for
the cyber truck that they now have to
pay thirty thousand dollars more to get
it so the best option tesla has is to
simply take a loss on these vehicles and
move on but when it's a guaranteed loss
there's no urgency to push out the cyber
truck it makes a lot more sense to scale
model 3 and y production first and get
to an even better financial position
before launching the cyber truck and
with the germany and austin factories
just now starting production these
factories will likely have their plates
full with the just killing production
till at least 2024 so in my opinion 2024
is likely the earliest the tesla will
focus on cyber truck production
aside from increasing prices something
else that's pushing back cyber truck
production is a lack of interest from
average consumers
now before tesla fanboys go to the
comment section and vigorously type
about how many pre-orders tesla has let
me explain while people who pre-ordered
the cyber truck and tesla enthusiasts
are still super pumped up about the
cyber truck the average person never
really cared at the end of the day given
how the cyber truck looks it's simply
not even a consideration for a
significant proportion of the population
and if you don't believe me just take a
look at google trends
if we compare model 3 and cyber truck
interest we'll see that not only was
initial excitement for the model 3
slightly higher than the cyber truck but
model 3 interest has stabilized at a
significantly higher level on average
model 3 interest has been 3 to 4 times
higher than the cyber truck over the
past 12 months now you might be saying
well so many people have already
received their model 3 and by this point
most people in developed countries see
model 3 is quite regularly on the road
so naturally interest for the model 3 is
going to be a lot higher
as a result we can't really compare
model 3 interest with cyber truck
interest until the cyber truck has been
on the road for a few years as well
while this is a valid point it doesn't
really change much from tesla's
perspective it makes a lot more sense to
double down on a vehicle that consumers
are already convinced about as opposed
to trying to convince people about a new
vehicle something else to note is that
while the cyber truck has millions of
pre-orders we have no clue how many of
these guys will actually follow through
if the deposit amount was 1 000 or 5 000
these pre-orders would be a lot more
meaningful but the deposit is only 100
and it's fully refundable
so i feel that a lot of people just paid
a deposit to get in line and they won't
actually make a purchasing decision
until they actually have to pay the full
amount if we take a look at tesla's
latest delivery numbers we'll see that
model s and x only account for 14 700
deliveries while the model 3 and y
account for 295 000 deliveries and if
the cyber truck is priced closer to the
s and x it's likely that its delivery
numbers will be closer to that of the s
and x after the initial delivery hype
dies down
also a lot of people who have cybertron
pre-orders also have pre-orders with
other companies and in the end they're
only going to go with one so not only
does google trends not paint a pretty
picture but we have no gauge of how good
follow through will be and these factors
just make it even less likely that tesla
commits to production any time soon
while the demand for the cyber truck
isn't quite clear yet the demand for
tesla's lower end vehicles is extremely
high even though model 3 and y prices
have risen substantially over the past
several months people still can't get
enough of these cars tesla is still
selling every car they produce and
they're struggling to even keep up with
the demand if i were to order a model 3
today it would take them two to four
months to deliver it to me if i order a
model y it would take them six to nine
months to deliver it and if i order a
model x it would take them eight months
to one year to deliver it also i should
mention that i live in austin so you
would think that deliveries are even
slower in other parts of the country
considering this a vehicle that has yet
to enter production is clearly not going
to have faster delivery estimates than
vehicles that have already been in
production for years something else to
consider is the supply shortage not only
has the supply shortage been leading to
higher prices but it's also making it
even harder for tesla to meet demand
and the last thing you want to do is put
the limited resources that you do have
into a vehicle with high requirements
take motors for example elon musk has
confirmed that initial cyber truck
production will be quad motorcyber
trucks meanwhile the base level model 3
only has one motor so instead of
building one quad motor cyber truck they
could build four base level model threes
which would be significantly more
profitable the same argument could be
made for battery cells as well if
resources were plentiful it would be all
right to divert some resources into this
behemoth but when you're strapped for
resources it makes no sense to divert
the resources that you do have into a
relatively low production vehicle with
high specifications
it's simply not as profitable and it
sacrifices the extra market share tesla
would have gained by simply sticking to
the model 3 and y
so given the extraordinarily high demand
for the model 3 and y it makes no sense
to focus on the cyber truck or any other
vehicle until tesla can meet the demand
for the 3 and y first
and by the looks of it that's not
happening until at least the second half
of this decade
on top of supply chains inflation and a
lack of follow-through data pushing back
the cyber truck we also have other
promise releases pushing back the cyber
truck the new tesla roadster and the
tesla semi were both announced years
before the cyber truck in 2017. now
let's say that supply chain concerns
inflation and demand for tesla lower end
vehicles all cool off by 2025 at this
point which vehicle do you produce first
sure cyber truck reservation holders
would have been waiting for six years
but tesla roads to reservation holders
would have been waiting for eight years
not to mention it they had to pay 45 000
to preserve their vehicle and what about
tesla semi reservation holders
these guys are institutional customers
like walmart and pepsi who paid millions
to reserve dozens of trucks
the last thing you want to do is lose
one of these guys as a customer now
tesla has started deliveries on the semi
truck but i think you get the point
tesla has other promised products that
may take higher priority than the cyber
truck which will just push back
production even more considering all
these factors the most obvious
conclusion that we can come to it is
that the cyber truck was more or less
just a pr move it was designed to
generate a bunch of hype for tesla and
it did precisely that the cyber truck
rubio literally kicked off tesla stock's
insane parabolic move which has garnered
the company more attention than ever
before and this attention is likely
leading to more vehicle sales than ever
before so whether the cyber truck ever
makes it to the road or not it was an
extremely successful product now this
isn't to say that the cyber truck will
never make it to the road either one of
elon's pet peeves is concept cars that
never make it to the road so i'm sure
elon will eventually pump out the cyber
truck at least out of principle but if
you have a reservation and or are
thinking about getting one just know
that you're likely going to be waiting
till at least 2024 and that's if you
spring for the flagship quad motor
version if you buy a lower end cyber
truck you're probably going to be
waiting till 2026 but that's just what i
think when do you guys think the cyber
truck will hit the roads comment that
down below also drop a like if you agree
that the cyber truck was a brilliant
marketing move and of course consider
checking out our international channels
to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you